cuál es el área del triángulo como
siempre los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta vamos a resolverlo juntos sabemos
que el área de un triángulo es igual a
un medio por la base por la altura
ponemos la altura en otro color
cuál es la longitud de nuestra base en
este caso nuestra base es 18 este lado
de aquí es nuestra base la base es 18 y
cuánto mide nuestra altura la altura que
vemos es 6 aquí nos están dando este
dato pero no siempre es así
así que nuestra altura es 6 ahora
simplemente tenemos que calcular cuánto
es un medio por 18 por 6 un medio por 18
es 9 y 9 por 6 es 54 y con esto
terminamos aquí tenemos 54 unidades
cuadradas